Vanessa Carlysle stole Wade Wilson's heart
in the 2016 hit Deadpool…
"What's a nice place like you doing in a girl
like this?"
...and the actress who played her, Morena
Baccarin, stole viewers' hearts along the
way.
Baccarin's been appearing in hit properties
since 2001, so you might feel like you've
seen her before—especially if you're a sci-fi
fan—but it may be hard to figure out exactly
where.
Here's why Vanessa from Deadpool looks so
familiar.
Way Off Broadway
Baccarin's first leading role came in the
small film Way Off Broadway, in which she
played a young actress trying to make it in
New York City.
Her character Rebecca was one of a group of
friends struggling to find a way to turn their
artistic ventures into a career while also
dealing with her own personal anguish.
Although the drama wasn't seen by many, it
earned mostly good reviews, with Baccarin's
performance in particular being singled out
for praise.
Firefly
In what's probably still her most well-known
small screen role, Baccarin played Inara on
Joss Whedon's short-lived series Firefly.
While many of the planned storylines surrounding
the character were cut short when the series
was canceled after just 14 episodes, Inara
was a fan favorite for her poise, charisma,
and intelligence.
Despite Firefly's short run, the series became
a cult hit and, years after being canceled,
it was brought back for a feature film, Serenity,
in which Baccarin reprised her role.
The O.C.
It might take a hardcore fan of The O.C. to
remember much about Matt Ramsey, Sandy Cohen's
partner during his tenure as the lead of the
Newport Group.
Matt had a brief love interest in Baccarin's
Maya Griffin, the daughter of Sandy's rival
Henry.
Although Baccarin only showed up in three
episodes of the series, her appearance is
still notable—it's where she first met her
future Gotham co-star and fiancé Ben McKenzie,
who starred as Ryan Atwood on the series.
It wasn't love at first sight for the two,
though; in fact, McKenzie has said he doesn't
remember seeing Baccarin on set and thought
he was meeting her for the first time when
they reunited on Gotham.
Awkward.
How I Met Your Mother
Baccarin only appeared on one episode of How
I Met Your Mother, but it was an important
one.
Her character arrived during Marshall and
Lily's season two break-up, with Baccarin
starring as Chloe, the only woman Marshall
actually dates during the brief separation.
While Chloe didn't get a happy ending, she'll
always be remembered by How I Met Your Mother
fans for inventing the name Swarley and pushing
the show's main couple back together.
Stargate SG-1
With Firefly, Baccarin developed a following
in the sci-fi community—one she expanded
with her next few roles.
Her first step back into genre fare came in
Stargate SG-1.
The actress played the villainous Adria for
five episodes of the series and briefly reprised
the role in the movie Stargate: The Ark of
Truth.
In addition to serving as her next big sci-fi
role, Stargate was also Baccarin's first real
chance to play a villain—a side she'd explore
in some of her later roles.
V
Baccarin's next big role also involved playing
a sci-fi bad guy—this time in the ABC series
V.
The revival of the high-concept '80s TV hit
featured Baccarin as Anna, the queen of an
invading alien species.
Baccarin earned multiple Saturn Award nominations
and a Scream Award nomination for her work.
Unfortunately, the series was plagued by low
ratings and high production costs, and was
canceled before it could reach a third season.
Guest starring roles
Like many actors, Baccarin has made the guest
starring rounds on TV, appearing on shows
like Heartland, Numb3rs, Medium, and The Good
Wife, in addition to a multi-episode arc on
The Mentalist as a murderous matchmaker.
Super fans of It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
may also recognize Baccarin from the show's
unaired pilot, in which she played the transgendered
Carmen.
Baccarin said she appeared in the episode
because she was college friends with writer
and star Glenn Howerton, but she unfortunately
wasn't able to continue with the series due
to other commitments.
Homeland
Baccarin earned an Emmy nomination for her
Homeland performance as Nick's wife, Jessica,
appearing consistently throughout the series'
first and second seasons, although she became
less of a staple in season three due to her
real-life pregnancy.
Jessica was written off the show before the
fourth season, opening her up for other projects
where her character got a little better treatment.
Still, despite the fact that fans didn't enjoy
her character, Baccarin demonstrated her dramatic
chops and earned a major award nomination
to boot.
Back in the Day
Making the jump to big screen comedies in
2014, Baccarin starred in Back in the Day,
created by and co-starring Smallville's Michael
Rosenbaum.
The movie's tone didn't go over well with
critics, with the film amassing a terrible
11 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
Fortunately, it didn't completely sink Baccarin's
comedy career.
Spy
Baccarin's rebound came in the form of Spy,
a hit comedy that sits at a much more impressive
94 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
In the movie, Baccarin plays Karen Walker,
the perfect super spy and a rival to Melissa
McCarthy's Susan.
A solid comedy showcase for Baccarin, Spy
was also one of her most notable pre-Deadpool
big-screen roles, proving the TV star could
work in a big budget blockbuster.
Gotham
Before Deadpool, Baccarin took on the role
of another beloved comic book character, portraying
Dr. Leslie Thompkins on Fox's Gotham.
Her onscreen love story with Jim Gordon has
spilled over into real life, and she and Ben
McKenzie got engaged in 2016 shortly after
the birth of their daughter.
Baccarin says Lee's pregnancy on Gotham wasn't
at all related to her own, though—just a
happy coincidence.
Let's hope their real-life romance goes better
than it does on Gotham.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!